c'est un ailier il sert un petit peu
tout faire il est pas flashy mais il est
polyvalent harrison ingram joueurs en n
6 et à standford et 16e du big board
envergure forces faiblesses projection
nba le tout en 30 minutes c'est
maintenant
trois experts donc pour parler harrison
ingram alan bonsoir bonjour je peux qu'y
bonjour bonsoir
ou bonjour
salut à tous
et julien bonjour bonjour enfin les gars
julien on rappelle notre spécialiste
côte ouest pour la n 6 on vous rappelle
aussi le format d'abord on va faire une
carte d'identité du joueur
son histoire son corps ses qualités
basket et puis ensuite on va poser
certaines questions autour de son avenir
de sa projection en nba on commence par
l'histoire le parcours et c'est hugues
qui s'en occupe hugues on écoute yes
d'écouté arts et sony g joueur qu'on
suit depuis un bout de temps maintenant
qu'on a pu voir et pas très longtemps il
a fait lui 19 où il a malheureusement en
gagner la médaille d'or contre une autre
équipe de france a' dorée de tenues par
habitant ou une bague diamant entre
autres au final où il avait un rôle
assez important sur les ailes mais
c'est un joueur qui est coté depuis
plusieurs années dans l'état du texas il
a été recruté par plusieurs gros
programmes on pense à b lors pour sa
danse carolin à on pensa à kansas etc
mais lui
ayant des résultats académiques assez
intéressant a pu s'engager avec stanford
qui on le sait est un programme de à
aimer jorrin de la pac thouels dont
s'occupe julien la confirmation
championne comme on l'appelle est
hélas les standards académiques pour les
rejoindre donc il s'est engagé avec eux
après le niveau de son jeu sinon au
niveau de la famille il ya un grand
frère qui joue et c'est l'université au
basket alors en 3e division donc
normalement pour lui c'est pas la nba
sauf si fine duncan robinson et ce
serait assez surprenant et chez les
parents on a des des gens assez aisée le
papa est propriétaire de plusieurs mac
do si j'ai bien compris alors voilà
investisseurs la maman aussi du coup et
c'est tout naturellement qu'il a été
nommé du coup le mcdonald's american vu
que bon les parents ont moins de
sponsoriser le projet déjà l'impression
mais sinon le joueur est un bon
basketteur n ya pas que la famille qui
fait qu'à pâques le chèque qui fait
qu'il a pu être nommé
très bien tout ça est complet joueurs
donc de standford cette année
effectivement stanford qui est autant
sur le plan académique que sur le plan
sportif une des toutes meilleures facs
de toutes les états unis on va parler du
physique d'harrison ingram donc et
plutôt en ailier mais à quoi il
ressemble est ce que il sait faire la
roue quelles sont ses mensurations ses
qualités ses défauts physiques c'est
julien qui nous ont pas non je ne sais
pas si c'est faire la roue mais c'est un
beau bébé comme c'est un ailier donc de
plus de deux mètres doivent de mettre un
de mes 3 il fait les mensurations 104 kg
grande envergure de
2 mètres dit sur quoi autour de m 10
c'est encore très élevé il est très
costaud très costaud des jambes très
costaud du haut du corps aussi gros
biceps et pectoraux
apparemment il a dit moi je veux dire
qu'il n'a pas un gramme de graisse
pas mal à les jours
et
est donc assez voilà costauds puissants
et alors ce qu'on veut ce qui frappe
quand on veut jouer c'est qu'ils n'ont
de junk empathie manque de pop même si
c'est un joueur qui est puissant qui se
déplace assez vite qui a une grande
envergure donc qu' on en parle et
sûrement défends ce qu'il est capable de
couvrir une grande surface par contre
dès qu'il ya des mouvements plus plus
verticale c'est du coup c'est pas plus
compliqué c'est que il saute pas quoi
alors c'est qui la gère notre sueur qui
saute d capable de john key mais c'est
pas sa qualité première le vertical
c'est pas trop son truc pardon de cernay
st donc c'est un gros ailier à ses
déliés qui est capable de bien gérer son
corps n'ont pas mal de situations
et on peut dire qu'il a il a plutôt du
style aussi physiquement moi je le
trouve qu'il est stylé aux u19 je
trouvais stylet avec ses petites tresses
et où la gauche au
dunk ou plus classiques en ce moment
ouais effectivement qu'est ce qu'on
achète chez harrison ingram si on se met
dans la peau d'un gm nba qu'est ce qu'on
draft pourquoi on en parle comme d'un
joueur potentiellement drafté alan
on achète un ailier qui peut passer
shooter dribbler moyennement moyennement
plus avec une marge de progression sur
certains de ces aspects là notamment
l'isère j'étais un joueur qui fait deux
mètres qu'à un niveau des making très
solide pour sa part sa taille très
intelligent qui fait peu d'erreurs
défensivement donc un joueur qui je
pense est insérables dans pas mal de
rotations a besoin toujours du ballon
pro vives était pas dans le même
contexte à 100 de ford pour se mettre en
avant mais qui peut comme on l'a vu
parfois aux u19 comme le disait dans ce
rôle est plus loin du ballon on défendre
mais ne détient en catch and shoot et je
pense avec quand même une marge de
progression c'est un 2002 il a 19 ans
alors physiquement il ya plus tôt finie
je pense pas qu'il va encore grandir qui
peut encore se développer mais dans son
jeu et dans d'autres aspects il ya de la
maturation encore à avoir un sac
intéresse
effectivement donc voilà la carte
d'identité de harrison ingram
est il un mélange d'harrison barn et
brandon et g non du coup on a un peu d
éléments de réponse là dessus il sera
choisi moins haut que ces deux là
mais quand même nom la 16e il est 56ème
gsp est ni les quarantièmes j'ai veillé
athlétique donc chez nous 16e il ya que
lui qui l'a finalement hors de son top
30 une est ce que tu peux nous expliquer
pourquoi
ouais
on a dit je suis assez d'accord avec ce
qui a été dit est bon partout excellent
nul part et je vais poser une question
un peu un peu provoc et je vais me
donner une réponse rapidement cicr à
quoi sur un terrain d'attaqué
en première année en tout cas est ce qui
peut jouer parce que on va on va
développer mais euh c'est pas un
finisseur près du panier julien il a dit
c'est pas un gros athlètes c'est pas un
tireur pour l'instant c'est un passeur
correct mais qui a pas un bon premier
pas c'est pas un dribble extraordinaire
dont globalement pour moi ce qui s'est
fait en attaque il pourra pas le faire
au nba et peut pas jouer loin du ballon
rond qui sert à rien et du coup une
équipe le ferai pas ou peu joué faudrait
un brême bon contexte pour lui s'il est
ok si avec andré personne à l'époque et
on voit que même pour un mec était plus
athlétiques comme isaac ont couronné
maîtrise ti
isaac au corps aujourd'hui en nba
malheureusement et là un rôle qui peut
ressembler à celui d'in g et joue très
très peu et on parle d'un quatrième
choix pour lesquels une équipe avait mis
beaucoup de valeur donc voilà on voit
très inquiet pour ça et qu'il n'ya pas
le bon prétexte je le vois pas se
développer
à l'année secouer la tête mais ça c'est
parce que tu as tu veux tu pense que
toutes les équipes veulent gagner des
matchs ce qui est parlé car en fait
toutes les équipes veulent pas gagner
des matches toutes les équipes veulent
pas jouer le titre des équipes qui font
des tentatives mêmes qui sont prêtes à
mettet gens négatifs sur le terrain dans
certains ont même dans les premières
années de mieux ça les dérange pas si
deux trois voire quatre ans à présent
elles ont le résultat de ça avec 5
grammes est bien moins après que des
joueurs de 21 22 23 ans mais il y en a
que 19 je trouve que l'âge c'est un
argument qui est important quand on aura
notamment au premier tour parce que
personne grammont le draft pour l'avoir
quand les scindera ce premier tour ces
quatre ans puis 60 potentiellement une
année supplémentaire à rui c'était
phoenix des fois tu fais des bêtises en
2e année mais
et quand même des
très rares je pense que ça peut être un
investissement dans oh voilà cette draft
très solide top 5 6 je trouve après une
deuxième partie de loterie où il ya
barrette des choix un peu différent je
trouve que dès le choix 14 15 mois
j'étais très haut sur lui au début j'ai
un petit peu revu à la baisse je
l'aurais pris dans lequel j'avais top 10
un moment non c'est pas aujourd'hui top
10 mais je trouve qu'en fait déjà il est
à elle c'est pour la position la plus
rare et là on cherche le plus de joueurs
nba il a dit lénine bon nul par mail à
19 ans dans un contexte pas bon pour lui
demander sûrement trop en faire
franchement c'est une sorte de pizza
autant je trouve qu'il ya deux ans il
nous avait enchantés par leur jeu alors
sur sur le sur le contexte peut-être
laisser julien en parler parce que c'est
lui qui il ya quand même poncet la pac
twelve cette année effectivement comme
alan disait julien c'est en fait c'est
une ford avait pas de hype en tant
qu'équipe et du coup peut-être que ça a
rejailli sur harrison ingram en tant que
prospects ce que tu peux nous raconter
le contexte de cette année à stanford
moi je suis 100% d'accord ecolan ya deux
ans on était les dix sites et de voir
l'équipe se construire de départ à la
grave l'année dernière c'était la cata
au niveau des sur coville c'était très
très dur et voilà et cette année une
grave il se retrouve dans une équipe où
il ya pas de meneur en fait il ya deux
arrière shooteur enfin qui sont plutôt
shooter mais qui sont pas organisateur
donc il est il doit organiser tout le
jeu offensif
il est entouré de deux ailiers qui joue
beaucoup qui sont plutôt des finisseurs
des purs finisseurs de l'air et
notre gars spencer jones
et
et puis il a des à part maxime dénommée
qui a joué de moins en moins pendant
l'année il a un peu un bûcheron au poste
5 qui voit la doxa laisse le contexte a
été un contexte équipe très compliquée
ça s'est jamais mis en route cette année
ça n'a pas cliqué hong a demandé
beaucoup beaucoup de choses notamment au
niveau défensif tout en exigeant de lui
de faire de gros efforts défensifs
voilà après moi je trouve qu'il ya quand
même une évolution contre ce qu'on a vu
même cette année là entre ce qu'on a vu
19 et la fin ou étendre des poules a pas
de point des choses comme ça il y en a
qui rentre seul toute détente et il faut
les voulait rentrer voilà même avec son
le fait qu'ils décollent pas trop c'est
toujours un petit peu bizarre de devoir
sauter mais moi je pense que
dans ce cas là luc moi je suis du côté
d'al ain où je me dis que une équipe qui
croit en son shoot au développement de
son shoot
voilà il ya quelque chose parce qu'il y
en avoir je pense que de toute façon il
va être obligé de souhaiter mieux ça
c'est sûr c'est un gars intelligent
comme tu l'as dit il était recruté
hausse par harvard
qui était dans le lot des programmes qui
venait d'avoir c'est un gars qui est
intelligent qui bossent y progresse
voilà après il tient pas même au niveau
universitaire il n'a pas tenu enfin
dernier match du tournoi au pacte wales
a c'était la cata quoi nous nous font si
c'était la cata il a montré ce soir
maria royal ça donc encore zaïre
williams l'année d'avant ouais mais il
pose un homme savait dès quand l'équipe
est dérangeant et regroupe déjà n'en
voyez vous bien quand le 5 étaient
présents il a commencé vraiment à
montrer
il avait une équipe plus équilibrée
aussi je pense la media legend et bissau
sinon voilà c'est les contextes font que
voir des fois ça semble pour certains
voire 10 mois sont là alors là ou là où
le gars a complètement raison et
peut-être sur d'autres points aussi
c'est que sans sentir sentir il
n'existera pas enfin ça on peut on est
on est à peu près tous d'accord là
dessus et pour le moment donc je me suis
procuré statistiques vous pouvez aller
aussi sur notre sur la sa page sur notre
site
effectivement 31% à 3 points avec une
fréquence très correct 7% possession à
peu près ce pas énorme mais c'est pas
mal sachant qu'il en coûte un quart en
sortie de dribble donc quitte apsad
baisse un petit peu son efficacité pas
beaucoup mais un petit peu
33% sur les jumper à deux points sais
c'est pas terrible
66 % aux lancers francs c'est pas
terrible
et près du cercle c'est pareil
51% et demi mais là par contre pas y
s'ancrer ils sont créés les trois quarts
et il a quand même réussi à voir alors
on parlera du fait de savoir accéder à
la raquette plus tard mais il par
rapport à ses qualités athlétiques qui
provoque quand même des lancers francs
ce qui est plutôt une bonne nouvelle
pour sa projection d'abord on parle du
shoot hughes est ce que qu'est-ce qu'il
ya des choses mécaniquement qui inquiète
dans le shoot ou est ce que c'est juste
l'efficacité
qu'est ce qui te fait penser que ça sera
compliqué à développer
au niveau de son tir où il n'est qu'à
dix pensaient pas hyper académique sa
part de bah c'est pas un geste hyper
fluide moi c'est plus le qui m'intéresse
pas ce qu'on voit qu'il ya beaucoup de
mécanique autrement qui fonctionne c'est
la confiance qu'il a dans le tir ce qui
est assez rassurant c'est que je trouve
qu'au fur et à mesure de la saison les
tirs y sont assez fluide il les prend
pas en 3d hésitations et cetera donc ça
peut se développer maintenant aller
danser francs joint juin difficile pour
moi sera jamais un créateur de tir parce
qu'on va parler du différend affirmé de
tir of the dribbles donc c'est pareil
pour moi du catch and shoot s'il peut
tourner à 35% catch and shoot ok ça me
samba il pourra jouer mais va falloir
arriver là et je suis pas je suis pas
convaincu que je préfère pas mouillé
alan est ce que tu as quelque chose à
dire sur son tir et qui est ce que aussi
tu as un exemple de joueurs qui qui
arrivait a à peu près avec ce profil là
en nba qui a réussi à se développer et à
avoir du temps de jeu et à se retrouver
à être un on parle pas de toute façon
d'un d'un potentiel option 2 3 d'une
équipe mais voilà d'un potentiel option
5,6 quoi se sont acheté 1 racing rome
après la loterie ou aux fourneaux dautry
pas dire qu'on envoie ses trois
meilleurs joueurs d'une équipe qui va au
titre c'est voir en lui un jour plutôt
polyvalent
qui fait qu'il peut faire du 3 4 mois un
exemple que j'ai c'est grant williams
mais c'est pas vraiment le même type de
joueur parce que dans notre gamme ses
plus grands plus robuste mais
l'enthousiasmé n'était pas un shooter
incroyable à tennessee justice ces trois
ans rate et n'hésite donc oui il y avait
des meilleurs pourcentages sur les
dernières années mais je trouve que dans
ce côté un peu lent robuste under ça
parce que moi ingram que je pense au
poste 4 en nba donc je vois en lui
potentiellement un joueur qui peut qui
est plutôt intelligent qui fait des
bonnes passes ça peut peut-être être ce
genre de deux jours là c'est peut-être
ce qui me plaît chez lui vu que j'adore
et grands tout câble sur mon degré draft
xo d'aujourd'hui pour moi un des
meilleurs rôles players digne des
meilleures équipes de nba donc ça peut
être le bon scénario entre guillemets
après sur le tir je me dis toujours que
c est quand on en parle avec des scouts
professionnels des coachs c'est la chose
la plus simple à travailler je préfère
qu'il aie aie ça a travaillé que le plus
mais king un jour avant % de passes
décisives en tant que freshman dans une
conférence du power 6 qui n'est pas
porteur de balle primaires c'est plutôt
c'est super intéressant g faisait ça
cette année j'avais des belles lectures
rien et hyper compliqué mais il fait les
choses bien et ça que j'aime
j'avais une comparaison
j'avais une comparaison pas d'écho
nantes
[Musique]
qui était un hôte williams mais qui
s'appelle khan reach
devrait laisser un super joueur suivra
ok fille après qu'henrik williams génie
c'est beaucoup mieux que près du cercle
populaire comme on l'appelle
julien est ce que tu tu valides ce que
disait uc sur la confiance dans le tir
est ce que toi mécaniquement tu as vu
des problèmes ou pas
moi je pense pas je pense pas
ce qui est gênant ses deux
lancers-francs quoi
qu'on regarde
et il a aidé en a pas rentrer trop acide
avait les mêmes pourcentages bowie 19
c'est pareil donc c'est vraiment quelque
chose qui le suit quoi donc voilà
elle a
à l'inversé rigolo
non j'ai regardé sur pjanic williams et
en vrai ils ont un peu le même corps je
trouve
et paient
l'isf était en train de me dire que
c'était pertinent ce que j'ai dit non à
la limite du grassouillet mais pas grave
on fait genre j'aime pas pour ça qu'elle
échoue la meuse en fait c'est pour ça et
vu que j'aime beaucoup qui est un riche
williams
hyper personnes il est déçu de lui même
en fait messieurs dames tout simplement
qu'enrique williams se joue pour
l'instant pas dans une équipe qui veut
gagner des matchs donc c'est assez
difficile de le projeter dans une équipe
de playoffs par exemple même si moi je
pense qu'il aurait un rôle à jouer sur
jeu pas entre 10 et 15 minutes peut-être
mais et le gala ne reste pas moins que
son nom qui joue à miami l'ont fait
jouer un ailier qui la fit a fini par
lever meneur et après dont il doit
abandonner il est renvoyé à même s'ils
se croient qu'ils ont fait a posté un
autre
style so why costaud voilà ce geste
eastwood chinois ep
après tu vois c'est quand vous voyez les
deux williams du regard leurs stats et
ils ont fait 3 ans initié donc ils ont
fini meilleur shooter rome en alors
qu'ericsson ingram ingram braila il fait
qu'un an donc on va dire ça henry
schutter s'il était resté deux ans de
plus il aurait amélioré le tir dans deux
ans n'aurait pas dit qu'il n'était pas
un bon shooteur on aurait dit voilà
c'est vrai un potentiel role player il
décide d'y aller plutôt n'diaye et de
travail tire dans quatre professionnels
il ya un an il ya très bonne aussi qu'il
ya pas mal aussi comme ça à chaud de
seconde partie de carrière mais je pense
qu'en fait on est globalement assez tous
d'accord sur le champ de même g stein
oui pas je vois je les confonds excusez
moi tu es un soin de lui mais qu de
florida state clippers - - beaucoup
m'ont beaucoup plus athlétique ternois
et pour le coup mais dans le genre où ce
qui était beau dengler airs décalé qui a
d'abord eu des missions défensives et
qui a mis un peu de tirs notamment
play-offs il a fait le milf l'an dernier
mais je pense qu'on a tous un accord
obligeant le même constat sur le fait
que c'est un joueur qui va devoir
développer son tir qui effectivement je
n'apporte pas positif au début sur le
terrain c'est jusque on n'accorde pas le
début la même valeur dans mon optique
quand tu es en fin de premier tour de
c'est de gagner des matches donc il
pourra pas jouer et j'ai pas d'un
scénario et je reviens souvent contre
l'anémié actuelle je ne sonne où tu
joues pas en première année l'état du
malade développer et où regarde tous les
équipements par le prometteur et donc
leur choix d'arte elles ont échoué cette
année mais peut-être qu'il ya le
contexte raffray j'ai pas regardé là je
te fais plus confiance que moi peut-être
qu'une équipe pourrie comme ok si qui a
35 choix pourrait aller sur les spurs en
espérant crachoir un équipement
plusieurs fois on est les premiers les
unit les échangent leur premier choix
pour à la deadline nous pourra récupérer
des joueurs
après oui tu as raison s'il arrive dans
un contexte qu'on fait pas jouer il joue
pas on l'envoie en jean sans un réel
projet mais en même temps vont nous ce
n'est pas notre rôle notre rôle c'est
plutôt dire de voir
si ça se passe bien ça peut être ça
voilà c'est ça
julien tu parlais parce que ça peut
aussi être une carte à jouer pour
gratter des minutes en début de carrière
tu parlais de son rôle défensif cette
année tu disais qu'on lui en avait
demandé quand même pas mal est-ce que tu
peux développer là dessus et défendent
est sûre quel type de profil et com
quelles qu'elles étaient ses qualités
particulières sur le système stan
fordien il est polyvalent mais où les
polyvalents quoi il a il a défendu sur
tout le monde il a défendu sur des
mineurs des arrières des ailiers il
commence les matches
sur au meneur et finit sur le pivot
voilà il est tellement costaud des gens
qui peut défendre des dégâts très
puissant il est assez
rapide c'est un gros mot quoi il est
capable de se retrouver sur un terrain
quand il est passé avec ses grands bras
il reprend son joueur dont qui peut
défendre des noirs plus petit et à tous
à tous les niveaux de la complète parce
que j'ai revu le match 2 b lors la cet
après midi
qui nous ont élevés nos médias kindle ne
passe pas quoi je vois donc qu'ils ont
ici un exemple voir les plus rapides de
la ligier mais veut dire il a l'art et
la couvrir du terrain et puis en plus il
a des mains seront pas parler il a des
paluches énorme moi j'aimerais tant les
j'attends le compagnon pour savoir
démesuré d'être des mains énorme et il
est capable de poser ses mains peu
partout il est beaucoup à salina très
vite on peut aussi être le le
pourcentage aux lancers francs je sais
que les joueurs qui ont vraiment des
grandes mains ils généralement gala un
petit peu avec l'adresse sur les qu'en
dira quand il faut poser le truc et qui
sont pas forcément en read quoi quand il
faut poser la main qu'il faut bien
s'appliquer
intéressant ce que tu dis défensivement
du coup tu parlais de akin jo sur les
autres oppositions pack twelve de deux
il y là il a tenu des gardes un peu
explosif
alors comme ça c'est une course qui me
rappelle de deux joueurs rapides en bacs
twelve comme cela des ailiers je faisais
je me rappelais d'arizona peut-être mais
il avait tenu
il a joué contre nature en aux u19 il
avait défendu sur radio stanley 2 qui
porte beaucoup de ballons a eu 19 oui
parce qu'elle a vu
face à l'équipe du canada effectivement
eu 19 ans il il est peu pris en défaut
après ce qu'on voit souvent et ça arrive
aussi contre b lors il défend des
contres il s'appelle leur ailier brown
c'est sa canne galbrun kendall drogue et
voilà il sut à avoir parce qu'il est
beaucoup il plonge beaucoup pour aider
dans la raquette et savoir sur les
souliers trois points mais ça c'est
assez classique finalement dé voir un
jeune qui veulent défendre beaucoup je
veux dire que kendall holt le gérer
jusqu'il ya dix reprises les filets
d'affilée à vider les soutes compte
récemment il s'est fait plaisir donc
voilà c'est
ouais moi il est polyvalent polyvalent
et très moi je trouve il faut quand même
le plat c'est quoi il est très présent
au rebond défensif de la mort il fait
tout le temps des blocs est un gars très
concentré et un impliqué en défense donc
par son coach et avec seulement deux
fautes sur 40 minutes ce qui est quand
même une très bonne voiture forme ans
très très bonne performance on parle
assez peu du nombre de fautes comme une
stat
c'est plus vrai pour les intérieurs
généralement puisqu'ils sont amenés à
être là en deuxième rideau et à faire
attention à bien placer leurs corps etc
mais c'est quand même parlant pour un
ailier comme ingram même s'il n'est pas
un playmaker il a un peu moins de 2% de
d'interception donc c'est pas
extraordinaire
et un peu moins de 1% de contre donc
c'est assez faible
hugues toi tu as le souvenir de match où
il a été plus plus en difficulté ouais
bon après on n'a pas non plus énormément
mais là tu es très pas des mecs comme
boogie ellis qui jouait là du côté de
memphis mais c'est un joueur qui va être
plus en galère sur les changements de
direction brut mais on va pas lui
demander de faire sans une bille est
normalement donc ils défendront pas
d'extérieur nba défendra des ailiers
pourra switcher sur des situations mois
du ballon et tout est dans ce cas là il
orientera latéralement et ça il le fait
très bien donc ça ne choque pas plus que
ça ça me gêne pas et c'est un très bon
joueur des deux défensives toujours bien
placé toujours bien en place reprend
rapidement derrière au niveau des
tireurs bonne dbz au repos et les écrans
retard donc aucun problème du club
défensif de mon côté ok il capte vite
c'est intéressant parce que tout le
monde n'est pas prêt à ingérer un
système nba dans son surtout à 19 ans
c'est pas évident à l'âne tu penses que
ça peut lui faire gagner des minutes
c'était habiletés défensives au witloof
je pense que c'est un genre qui fait pas
d'erreur peu d'erreurs plus que le côté
plus mais king dont il est pas vraiment
un playmaker ce pas preneurs de risques
comme tu l'as dit les stocks sont pleins
crois donc les styles les interceptions
et les contre par contre le dieu que
très bon défenseur dead leader vocal
fait peu d'erreurs basse a ses limites
dans un début de guerre plus important
que le côté playmaker dans ta gueule ou
d'un d'un profil comme ça va faire un
joueur qui saura se placer quiche en
situation de switch va pas va pas se bat
pas perdre son joueur va peu pour la
commune y a pas être perdu que quinze
joueurs qui voient là serait peut-être
un shakedown genre sur le périmètre
quelque chose comme ça je pense que ça
peut être un bon un bon l'autre chose
pour lui et je pense aussi qu'il va très
bien interviewé au combat il a gardé un
profil de l'important lorsqu'elle
rentrait très important et c'est
important donc on pense quand même dans
l'ensemble qu'il est un petit peu sous
côté paris spn était athlétique et
spillane j'étais quand même surpris 56e
c'est vraiment bac
derrière des joueurs j'ai plus les noms
mais jules des cdd non cumulable
derrière des joueurs qui sont plus forts
que lui aujourd'hui mais c'est toujours
le débat des freshman tous les drops
parce que moi je pense turcan purpose
fin de premier tour je peux je peux
j'aime bien prendre ce risque de même on
a vu et puis on voit des fois des
défraiements et qui sont capables de
vous même s'ils sont ils ont des soucis
alors qu'à dans leur carrière nba même
si la région des contextes où ils sont
pas sûrs d'avoir du temps de jeu et ben
oui tu peux quand même récupérer un peu
de de miettes et de bien développer nous
derrière oscar tshibuyi bon alors ça
c'est pas normal par exemple
j'aime bien aux quartiers bour et un pas
de problème mais
et c'est compliqué
manu est ce que tu peux sortir et
revenir quand je t'appelle stop c'est
pour la vidéo
merci
est-ce que vous avez une comparaison
pour le plafond de d'harrison énorme
puisque on sait on sait on s'est projeté
sur un aller un
scénario assez optimiste sans être très
optimiste mais parfois le très optimiste
arrive on a l'exemple en ce moment dans
les playoffs nba avec les les jordan
poule tyrese maxi et et compagnie qui
brille même site à erize maxi on le
savait un peu amènes à
son sens sans fard au nez est-ce que
vous avez un scénario idéal chez pas il
se développe il arrive et se développe
il gratte des minutes il défend il
développe un randle on n'a pas parlé de
son brandon
ce qu'il est fonctionnel ou pas en deux
mots hugues du secteur bien regarder ça
il peut changer de nom c'est déjà pas
mal l'un par un premier pas hyper
explosif maîtrise pas trop il est assez
épais mis sur domine tant aux puissances
méchant du dry d'uniformes est capable
quand même de créer un petit écart et
ils passent très bien donc moi ça me va
pour delà pour du renversement de la
finition d'action et et faire
fonctionner une attaque survient au quai
julien est ce que tu as hâte à un
scénario idéal pour lui quel genre de
joueur il peut devenir pas quel joueur
avec les mêmes qualités mais quel genre
de joueur
en personne même si je sais pas ce qu'il
est long tu vois moi je pensais à ce lot
mots ok elle mélange entre slough mots
et
des zones assez nouveau avec dieu me
voilà
à l'année moi je reste sur grant
williard
si ça marche quand williams williams se
voit des minutes en plein jeu dans une
équipe qui joue le titre
bon c'est vrai c'est vrai qu'ils jouent
le titre c'est jarrige soucy au complet
ou didier robert et la wii 6 euros béret
pallanne faut toujours avoir de son
robin
huc
alors de façon je sois je remonte un peu
moins optimiste que nous globale si la
vraie vrai dire qu'il se met en place
autoporteur junior mais avec un vrai
vrai tir qui se
moquaient
qui a un rôle quand même
messieurs sonne la cloche on a fini sur
harrison ingram sauf si quelqu'un veut
ajouter quelque chose
non question supplémentaire la question
supplémentaire la question bonus qui n'a
rien à voir généralement avec le basket
ball même si un petit peu harrison
ingram j'ai tapé harrison célèbre sur
google
j'ai trouvé évidemment plein de harrison
très intéressants dont le premier civil
à marcher sur la lune qui était
troisième je crois mais le premier étant
harrison ford harrison ford a joué de
rôle iconique à l'e3 rôle iconique mais
deux rôles qui se ressemble un peu dans
le caractère et la jouer en solo indiana
jones et ce sont deux personnes qui ont
beaucoup de chance qu'ils sont un peu
charmeur et qui sont un peu meneur
d'hommes mais qui sont qui font le bien
quand même en solo il hésite un peu mais
à la fin
qui est le en solo ou le
indiana jones de cette draft
voilà la question que je vous ai posé un
peu en avance mais pas beaucoup je sais
pas si vous avez eu le temps d'y penser
si je me lance je vais peut-être le
volet à julien donc je suis désolé j'ai
d'allentown silva la draft un peu le mec
le deuxièmement un peu insolent un peu
trash armée mais bon gars et en plus
pour envoyer des lobes en nba pour avoir
des skywalker à ses côtés parfait
ok pas mal pas mal d'haleine tellerie
joueurs d'arizona ont il peut être pas
qu'il va peut-être pas partir à la drave
d'air puisqu'il n'a pas encore à l'heure
où on enregistre déclaré sa candidature
julien mais j'avais pensé à l'intérêt
pour le côté sale gosse tu vois de
deuxième solo mais sinon je vais penser
à les griffin aussi parce qu'il ya tout
le temps boyle a été blessé tu as
souvent dans dans une nana jones il se
prend d spontour des pelles
moitié cassé donc je n'avais jamais
pensé à lui oui c'est ce qui me
paraissait évident c'était c'était rails
mais ne guère en parler quoi mais qui ne
va pas à la draft du coup et weimer
aqesss effectivement un peu en plus avec
le le côté aventurier qu'on imagine
chéri meira caisse le joueur de ucla
mais qui revient au ucla qui va jouer
avec deux freshman très intéressant et
prochaine à marie baye laye numéro 2 des
lycéens qui arrive en acier et adam bona
turcs kurdes turcs au nigeria turcot
nigérien merci à l'âne vas-y donne moi
ton en solo de la nav c'est jean montéro
côté avant la chorier je vais découvrir
des nouveaux des nouveaux horizons de
nouvelles ligues meneur d'hommes c'est
un peu en meneur d'hommes c'est vrai
avec la république dominicaine us
airways
la overtime élite c'est un peu le leader
de son équipe oui la cia lev ati
mobility montgomery avant qu'ils aient
un peu refoulées aux frais des équipes
il sait faire jouer les autres mettre
les autres en lumière mais il est assez
flashy aussi donc j'ai choisi jean
c'est parfait jean montéro d'haleine
terry et hadji griffin conquis on leur
souhaite d'être un destin à la indiana
jones alan solow je sais pas mais à la
indiana jones est sympa comme
messieurs merci
c'était dans notre podcast sur harrison
ingram vous pouvez aller voir sa fiche
sur envergure point c'est au évidemment
il ya un scouting report et y en at il
un juste une win bien sûr écrit par
julien ici présents
et puis vous pouvez aller voir tous les
autres scouting report on a plus de 70
je dirais sur les potentiels drafté
cette année et ça va encore se remplir
dans les semaines à venir donc voilà on
vous donne rendez-vous en podcast
n'hésitez pas à vous abonner sur votre
plateforme hésitez pas à vous abonner
sur youtube si vous regardez sur youtube
est allé voir notre vidéo à vous abonner
également at which avec le stream tous
les vendredis soir animé par hugues ici
présent le seuil
merci à tous et à très bientôt sur
envergure ciao